well i think yeah i think you're right
the nature of nature
is changing and and we seem to be
centrally caught up in that the
the existential or modern view of human
beings is that we are somehow
have slipped from the control of nature
or
were created by god in opposition to
nature
so there's this whole thing about how
nature can be plundered and pillaged
because
it exists for us it is somehow a
thing for us to deal with but
nature is changing and we are the
primary evidence for that i don't think
we've slipped
out of control of any of the governors
of this planet i mean that's
taking a lot of pride
upon yourself to believe that a bunch of
monkeys could truly
run against the grain of the planetary
destiny
it's rather that we occupy a special
niche a special role in the planetary
ecology we are apparently ourselves
catalysts for change and
we tend now because we have so much of
it
to think of this as a bad thing but
perhaps it isn't a bad thing uh
i was taught when i was studying botany
and ecology that
before human beings before the rise
of land clearing fire using human beings
the major factor on earth
driving the evolution of plants
the major factor was the meandering
habits of rivers because
because rivers as they meander create
vast flood plains and sand bars of
empty land and it's into
empty land that newly evolving
plant species migrate and compete
so before the advent of human beings
it was the the land clearing properties
of rivers
drove vegetable evolution on this planet
well once human beings appeared
then land clearing began on a vast
scale and
plant speciation consequently increased
a pace
now granted the kind of plants that were
promoted by this
are from our point of view aesthetically
uh unsatisfying it was the
geographer carl sauer who said man
found the world a climaxed rain forest
he will leave it a weedy lot
you see what happened was that slow
growing annual plants like trees
were replaced by rapidly growing
very heavily seeding annual plants
but we have to recall that the
appearance of flowering plants
period is something that has happened
very late
in the life of the earth concomitant to
the appearance of mammals
on a large scale come the flowering
plants
so we are agent of some kind of
planetary
change we always have been a point film
made to me
um at lunch was
one of the major reasons for the
evolution of pastoralism
the domestication of animals and then
agriculture
was the fact that the hunting had
actually become
tough work because we had killed
off whole populations
and and this was very very early there
was a major
paleontological conference held three
years ago i think in toronto
where they concluded that the human
impact
on ice age fauna was immense
in the 40 000 to 25 000 year ago
period well this is supposedly in the
pristine era of ecological balance
people don't realize uh
how long the human impact
has been going on on the planet again
quoting carl sauer he or describing his
ideas
he believed that there was no such thing
as a natural grassland he believed that
every grassland on this planet was an
artifact
of human burning and that given the
absence of human beings grasslands
cannot arise that what you get instead
are climax to forest ecologies
he made a pretty good case for that what
about the
herds of gazelles and all those they
wouldn't be bouncing around in a
particularly dense forest would they
no um it's thought actually that
or or what sauer talks about is that the
grassland
thing was a kind of management
of the ecosystem to produce uh
food you know it said that at the time
that the spanish arrived in california
this was one of the most heavily human
impacted environments on the planet
that the california indians managed
california like a vast
system of natural parks and
with yearly burning all kinds of
artificial ways of enhancing the
environment in fact
interesting experiments were done where
they went to the very earliest
missions in california and
obtained permission to take the adobe
blocks
of these earliest missions and as you
know straw
was used as a binder in the making of
adobe
so these scientists would take these
very old adobe bricks
and they would dissolve them in gentle
solutions of acids
and then they would study the straw that
was left
well they showed that there were over a
dozen
kinds of cereal grains
in california when the spanish arrived
under cultivation by the indians
that no trace of which now remains
large kerneled wheat and oat-like
plants producing a large amount of
nutrition
so so human management of the
of the ecosystem and i think that it's
been shown by
sauer and others that you can promote
the evolution of
grasses of which all cereals or grasses
simply by repeated burning you see
sauer's argument that there were no
primary grasslands bait was based on the
fact that
every single species that you find
in the grasslands you can also find in
the forest at the edge of the grasslands
as a minor component of the forest
but there are no no truly new
species in the grassland so he said what
the grassland is
is a totally impoverished forest ecology
and it's been impoverished by burning
and repeated burning allows
only the annual plants to get a foothold
and they rapidly evolve therefore and
then through human selection
and reseeding you get this promotion of
cereals
and as you know it was the evolution of
rye
that allowed human beings to occupy
ever more northerly parts of the
northern hemisphere
and so forth and so on so we have always
been
this catalytic species always
involved in implementing and causing
change uh it's only in the last
50 years at most but anybody ever
noticed this and then asked the question
is it a good
thing or not because we are romantics
we do have a great nostalgia
for eden which and you touched on this
it's very interesting if you look at the
genesis
story what this is immediately about
is a drug problem
you know somebody has a drug and they're
telling other people that they shouldn't
use it
and the other people are not following
the rules and
are using the forbidden fruit and so
then they have to be
punished and it's a story about
struggle over who gets to use what
plants and who has the say-so
about it so we emerge onto the stage of
western culture
with the out of the dawn age with this
whole set of complexes
about about our role in nature
whether we are natural or unnatural
whether we are on the side of the angels
or on the side of the gods
and it all revolves around plants and
plant use you know the gnostics
took the whole myth of genesis and just
turned it up turned it on its head they
didn't reject it
they just changed the players and said
obviously the serpent was a messenger
from the true god
and these poor people were imprisoned
in the iron fortress of the mad god bill
dabot
and the higher and hidden all father
sent in his mercy the serpent
to try and turn these people on to the
fact
that the guy in charge of the garden
wasn't god he was in fact some kind of
renegade some kind of pie radical
character
who should be overthrown and so they
worshipped the snake
and and glorify that act of rejection
of of ildawa
[Music]
you